Well Jack Diamond thank you for for
coming down to do this interview it's
the first interview you've done since
you were cleared um you're still a
professional footballer yeah but you've
had to live for years now with the smear
of being an accused rapist I mean first
of all how do you feel that it's it's
over yeah um I'm obviously glad that
it's over but you still had to Ure what
I had to endure so I mean I'm obviously
glad that can talk about now but it's
it's not it's not a breath of relief
like everyone thinks it will
be take me back to to really what
happened here you connect with this
woman on Tinder yeah which is for those
who don't know it's a dating app it's
very popular and you start seeing each
other how would you categorize a
relationship yeah like as we started
obviously I was young this is two years
ago as well so how old were you at the
time I was 19 when I first met her so
and how old was she she was 19 20 as
well so you're two young people
teenagers and you you connect on Tinder
what was it that you saw about her you
thought might be um well it was just
looking for a sexual casual relationship
as you do um when you're young and she
she live close to us umly I can't speak
too much about everything but yeah just
ended up speaking and getting on getting
on quite well so and you had a sexual
relationship for I think a year right
yeah yeah how often would you see each
other every two three weeks casual not
nothing like planned wasn't too serious
um but was there anything in that period
that gave you alarm bells or was it
perfectly normal I think at the end
there was a bit of alarm Bell there was
an incident that happened where maybe
sure that should like me a bit more than
I liked her and wanted something a bit
more serious um so that's when I kind of
disconnected for a while but that was
like the first time I kind of came into
contact with her and started speaking
you know obviously having a relationship
but until then you were both in for the
same thing as far as you were concerned
i s of of transactional sexual
relationship you see each other for sex
and you get on well but that's it it's
not a full blown relationship as such
yeah definitely that's how you would
yeah that's how I would describe it
would either of you see other people at
the same time or not uh I'm not sure it
wasn't it wasn't really like a regular
checkup thing kind of chat we just say
are you fre this time you know what I
mean very casual and then you know what
I mean say each other then whoever would
text next but let's get then to the the
night that she says that you raped her
it's you've now been cleared of all all
charges obviously what happened well it
was nothing out the ordinary at all that
night um the only thing that didn't
obviously happen was was one of the only
times we didn't have sex um had you gone
out that night or I'd been out to see
cuz my season had finished so I went to
see a few friends um just locally and
then I got back at about 10 half 10 and
then as I usually would or she would
like on a Saturday night or whatever um
would give each other a text say what
she was doing and then she end up coming
around U to your place to my place at
about 20 minutes after I called her so
and what happened well the she she came
in um just let herself in because
obviously I've been seeting her for so
long now was very informal so she just
came and let herself in came upstairs
and then she's undressed and got on my
bed um and then just normal just ch
chatting a little bit and then start
kissing touching everything like this um
which he says was all consensual and
then I've I've like initiated initiated
like doing stuff she's also done that
just like um like touching and stuff
like that um and then she's basically
got on top of us to try and initiate sex
and I've I I don't want to have sex
basically you weren't in the mood I
wasn't I I wasn't in the mood like I
just just got home was very late so then
she's um turned over and kind of like a
strop as I thought but obviously I kind
of brush it off as like oh she just in a
bit of a huff so then I have initiated
sex back and we're just kissing again um
and then I'm on top of her and she's
just said I think the moment's gone and
I was like right okay no problem got off
and then about 30 minutes later she just
got up and left um and said she's went
do you want to suppos keys with letter
box and lock the door and everything and
I was like yeah thanks no problem so you
felt this was the end yeah was just like
I thought she was just in a bit of a
huff I didn't think anything serious she
didn't say anything do you know what I
mean um I was very innocuous or I didn't
really understand anything had happened
I didn't think there was anything
nothing no no nothing nothing that would
suspect that she would
be angry or when you talked about the
alarm bells that happened before that
what was that just I would show Texas
and say do you want to do like other
activities um that was obviously like
more of a relationship activities and
you didn't want to do that no like cuz
I'd always say I was like listen it's
just I'm not looking for anything
serious but you were always honest with
as concern but she clearly wanted
something maybe a bit more than you
could give her yeah but then she would
always say that oh yeah I know that's
fine but then she would always drop
these little things that would obviously
mean that I would it it looks like more
than it actually is so she she left yeah
and she left the keys in the house
through the letter box locked the door
put the keys and she's gone yeah and
then what's the next you hear um about
half in the morning um cuz I was
actually meant to be going on like a end
of season like party kind of thing with
a team that i' been at uh so I was
expecting someone to come pick us up um
and then I thought oh well bit early do
you know what I mean I'm not supposed to
be getting picked up yet and then
obviously the police came with the door
to your house yeah um and I didn't
really know what to say and they're like
hi Jack we all Who You Are come come in
I'm like yeah fine and I still didn't
have a clue just like an incident
happened with a girl last night you know
and I was
like like just in shock because
obviously I knew exactly what went on
that night and you've known her for a
year yeah of course and I think the fact
that they came and said something had
happened and I knew nothing had happened
that it was just instant in the dark
like what did you feel in that moment
just absolute shock because I didn't
know what could have been said because
obviously I knew whatever's been said is
obviously false what happened then um
well I'm obviously trying to text my
friend saying something's came up I
can't make it they're trying to take my
phone like do you know what I mean like
and then mentioning football saying how
was football and stuff so like my head's
just spinning at this point um and
they're like we're going to have to take
you down to the station to get your
fingerprints done but obviously at the
time um I got arrested for digital
penetration uh so so the rape didn't get
mentioned until the day I got charged so
I didn't have a clue that was going to
be in and obviously it's a big
difference you know I mean it's a
horrendous crime so and then I've got
taken to the station um walls end I
think it was and I was there for they
didn't didn't really say anything just
took me took me clothes took me trainers
then I was in a Cell from about 9:00
till
about three I didn't hear so you're
you're a professional footballer at 19
you you're living your dream yeah
earning money playing the game you love
everything going well for you and then
suddenly you're in a prison cell yeah
and you're being accused of assaulting
this girl yeah you don't know quite the
full scale of the charges at that stage
but you MH in those hours what is going
through your
head just disbelief and obviously they
said was it was digital penetration
that's what they said I was getting
arrested for um and I didn't know what
that was you know what I mean I'm I was
20 19 20 21 at the time I didn't have a
clue I didn't have a clue what it was so
I'm saying what's this what does that
mean and then they're briefly telling us
um saying they need to swap my fingers
and I'm thinking what the hell so then
they've took us to the the cells and I'm
just sat there thinking I don't know
what I think that was the scariest thing
because I didn't know what what had been
said what she said terrifying yeah well
because I'm sitting there thinking if I
can get arrested for something that I
don't even know what's what's being said
I just knew whatever is going to be said
is going to be false could you call
anybody
the the asked us to if I wanted to but
um I don't really think it would have
been a nice phone call to receive know
from my
parents um so I was just sitting there
thinking well if this is if this is
happening what what am I going to do you
did your whole life flash before you did
you think this might be the end yeah
yeah because I was like well I'm
finished I was like I'm going to get out
here get my phone back and it's just
going to be full of everyone's going to
know Sunderland yeah footballer yeah
arrested did for sexual assault right
yeah so obviously the fear of that and
then I've went into um I think it was
about 4:00 I finally got got into a
interview to give a statement um so I've
been there since like 9 did you have a
lawyer yeah I got just a Barr that the
called um a solicitor sorry um a duty
solicor yeah so he just got called
um and when he came then he kind of like
told us everything that happened and uh
she hadn't give a statement so I was
like what she what you mean she does not
give a statement uh So what had happened
is she basically said a passing com into
our mate like say know he Tred to force
himself on his or or something along
them lines um and then I met basically
told her father and her dad's hit the
roof as you would um and like it's it's
unbeli spiral out of control and then at
that point well even in the T just to
saying oh well she doesn't want to bring
the police she said her dad no no don't
call the police and everything but as a
father as you would that's the first
thing you do call the police um so then
she's not saying he's basically just
saying reln what's being said off this
um and I've I've got there and there was
a bit of a relief because I was like oh
my dad's rang in like it it's not her
she's her dad's just angry or something
I was trying to like make it trying to
rationalize yeah yeah um and then the
solicitor basically saying oh well if
you want to talk you can talk and I was
like yeah I've got nothing to hide I
just tell the truth I'll just tell
exactly what's happened like it's
innocuous it's not it's not going to um
harm anything of me so then I've told
them and theyve went all right yeah no
problem and then you'll get a letter or
something um so then that was it and
then I think there was one more point
where I got called in for another St
another interview did you tell the club
at this stage or not
um yeah I think I I told the club cuz
they found out like a day later and then
I've been called in for a meeting and
then I've had to tell them the whole
story and they were like all right okay
that's fine
um and then what about your family how
did they react oh well it was it was
tough because my family thought I was in
the lead they thought I was out and then
my mom's texting my phone obviously
asking us uh where are you how are you
doing obviously she's not heard from us
for like six six seven hours um so then
I told her I was like uh I'm just got
out police station um she must have been
horrified yeah yeah I think she just
hung up the phone um so then I was
texted I was like I'll come straight
around um and then basally went and told
him and then a horrendous thing for you
to have to do yeah um uncomfortable
obviously cuz I going well how how can
this happen if and I'm I'm still in
shock so I'm still trying to think how
has this actually
happened um and then I obviously try to
reassure them because I don't want them
to be worrying about me um
so yeah and then not heard anything for
a while and then she still hadn't give a
statement at this point had it got
public at the stage or no no so she
hadn't she hadn't give a statement for
like a month and I was waiting to see
well what's going to happen where's it's
going to
go um was it on your mind all the time
yeah yeah um because I was I was just
about go on holiday obviously because
the season had finished I didn't really
want to go anymore because obviously I
was terrifi TI of girls at that point
cuz I was like what's what's happened
here I don't want to go away anywhere I
just want to did you tell any of your
teammates um yeah cuz I lived with one
of them at the time um Anthony Patterson
I live with was he there on the night
yeah uh she'd actually text him on the
night as
well um and it was the story gets a bit
wild but I've went to the toilet in the
middle of the night and she's she said
that she thought we were both going to
gang R um because I went to the toilet
and and then she she said that she left
the house to our dad at that point which
I hadn't should weird like she could
have just left if that was really the
case I've came back and then half an
hours went by then she just got up and
left um so when was the moment you
realized you were going to be
charged so I didn't hear anything for
about a year uh and then kind of just
thought Arts went away like ridiculous I
went on lawn um had to tell the lawn
Club to car I think no it was linoln I
went went to l first yeah so um and then
obviously they found out so I had to
have the conversation tell the story
again to someone I'd never met before in
my life um which was uncomfortable again
um but then I've kind of just forgot
about it slowly thinking oh I just went
away um and then I think i' came home
midweek for some reason I think I was
shopping with my mom at the time and
then I got the call off the solicitor um
who obviously with last time and I've
not heard him for a year so I was
thinking oh my God like my heart just
sunk so I've answered the phone and I
just went listen I'm out with my parents
at the moment can I call you when I
return home he's like
yeah um and then I'm just obviously
praying for the best because I know that
this is obviously going to be an answer
uh so I've dropped my man back off
because I was like good or bad news I
don't want to be there when I don't want
her to be there when I here so um I've
went back at my house and then rang him
back uh and he just said I think you
might want to sit down um you've been
charged
of rape and digital penetration and
obviously that was the first time I'd
even heard about the rape so ium what
did that word do to
you I just couldn't understand it it was
just like at that point it was just like
everything's done um like football
wasn't in my
head like friends weren't in my head it
just like my family like I was just
thinking this is going to change
everything of course so like at that
point I just thought well football's
never happening do you know what I mean
that's it the end of your career
because it was just like if this can
happen can go this far I was like I'm
done because if it can go this far then
it can and when did your name get out in
relation to that charge two days later
two no a day later it it was in all the
papers yeah and me that when you're
named next to the word rape is as bad as
as bad as yeah it can get for you right
you're a young man and this is what
everyone is reading about you yeah what
was that like to have to read headlines
about yourself like that uh it was scary
because
obviously I knew what what would went on
what had happened and then I'm sat there
kind of defenseless can't say listen I
didn't do this you know what I mean I
can't just pop up everywhere and go
every new story I'm innocent I'm
innocent because you're not really
allowed to you're just what was the
reaction from people in the streets and
stuff um I didn't really leave the house
for about a week or two um I'd went cuz
I was at home at the time and Liv by
myself the the moved my friend the club
and moved my friend out the house um and
they suspended you right yeah so a day
later I got
suspended and obviously I remember being
in the meeting and just thinking what am
I going to do like I've played football
for 18 years of my life like and now it
just stopped and then obviously I've got
this this over my head so I was like and
how long was it until the the trial um a
year so you basically this is two years
of your life you've had to live with
this yeah and when it gets to
trial and you see this girl again
presuming that's the first time you've
seen her again is it yeah well I didn't
see her she was uh blocked off from
everyone um and nobody knew who she was
no well this is the thing like um
obviously when the police released the
statement they've named us they've put
me addressing it big picture of me with
man rapes well the name just said Jack
Diamond with uh and then I'm reading
that and I'm thinking how how can they
do this do you know what I mean um and
she remains Anonymous yeah Tu his day I
me you can't say who it is the police
are supposed to be there to protect us
though putting that next to my name with
me addressing first thing I'm thinking
is someone's going to come to my house
or someone's going to try and do
something did you get any bad incidents
like that no but like you're thinking
about it all the time think about it
like the first the first week I would
obviously see me parents quite a lot the
first first week um and i' would be on
my
driveway and I would just not not get
out the car until there was no one in
the street you know what I mean I
wouldn't want to speak to my neighbors
cuz obviously they all know knew um so I
think I kind of just avoided all contact
with everyone at the time except my
family eventually at the end of the the
trial how long did it last the trial um
it was about 5 days I believe yeah and
at the end of it you had a jury yeah and
you're looking at these 12 people and
they're going to decide yeah the rest of
your life yeah and when they give the
verdict what is that feeling like when
you're waiting as you see them about to
deliver the
verdict uh well it was a bit crazy
because we thought it was going to be a
day cuz it was only about an hour left
of the the actual Court time so we've
went to the shop to be like oh it's
probably going to be another day so I'm
think I'm have to wait another day for
all this um and then I think we've
literally got the bottom of the stairs
and my dad's text was saying the clerk's
looking for you so like my barers
panicking thinking
oh this is it they' like they can't have
done it this quick
um and then came in and I was just
looking forward I didn't want to look at
them didn't want to look at anyone and
obviously because it was two accounts I
heard the first not guilty and then I
heard the second and
then yeah it just it was crazy but the
feeling
of like relief lasted I would say about
2 minutes really yeah and then because
then after I just think all of this for
7 minutes all of this for this to be
this quick I was like how ridiculous
were you emotional in that moment yeah
you cried yeah I think my whole family
did my bar cried what was your Barr
cried really yeah that's unusual yeah
well Gareth darer he uh he worked quite
close he saw us this whole time um yeah
she cried you're barass yeah because
when I came out of when I first got
charged obious I went away for a bit um
he looked after us all this time and
kind of prepped us had a real Bond yeah
how was your mom when you got cleared
yeah she was just in tears my sister and
me dad every every single person you
know what I mean
and I think that was the the hardest
thing as well because obviously I told
her this whole time I was like I was
putting on trying to be confident said
it's going to be all right it's going to
be all right more for my family because
I think if theyve saw me struggling um
and upset but I think it was just I was
happy for them as well how long did the
jury take to do deliberate seven minutes
seven minutes yeah so you went through
over two years of hell and it took a
jury just 7 minutes to clear you yeah
which is an emphatic repudiation of what
this woman had been claiming they just
didn't believe what she was saying but
you were dragged through this hell for
so long yeah and even as you sit here
now a cleared man you know for the rest
of your life it'll have Jack diamond and
the word rape and you'll be forever
associated with that yeah when you play
football you're going to play well I
don't know what's been happen what's
been happening with the opposition fans
do they ear abuse I did the other the
other day I came off uh came off injured
to walk past the hall away that was your
first game back yeah um s God who were
you playing you were playing for carile
against yeah L orand and what happened
uh well I've came off injured um and I
was obviously at that point I was
annoyed anyways um but then I've had to
walk around the whole pitch cuz you
can't just walk off for quickness and
obviously I got the chance straightway
as W past them and I was just thinking
what was the chum um she said no diamond
she said no um really yeah but I was
kind of expecting this um it's still
horrible yeah and you're probably going
to get that from away fans everywhere
how you going to deal with that
mentally I think just with everything
this whole time has just been something
positive will come out of it or there's
something I can do to either use it to
fight fuelers um just trying not to
react do you know what I mean I think
this whole time has been mentally like
strong for us because I've obviously had
paper's name is basically called us the
worst thing in the world um my family's
been obviously Associated like I've not
just been the one struggling through it
like they took a few weeks off work
because they were embarrassed right
everybody of course it's it's the worst
imaginable thing yeah you're accused of
rape all your family have to deal with
that or your friends have to deal with
that yeah well it's it's everything
because I'm suspended can't use anything
and then do you do you hope to go back
to Sunderland and play for
them at a moment in my career I can't
see um obviously up my contract's up in
the summer so I can't see playing for
them again but obviously the whole time
I've been suspended because of my name
obviously attached with this word like
people I've seen for 10 plus years jym
for keeping fit do you know what I mean
like the didn't one Us in it's not the
didn't want us in but the because the
newest they're like yeah you can come in
but not when anyone else is a you know
what I mean you're like a pariah yeah so
at that moment when you played again
last week and you ran back ran out on
the pitch yeah what did that feel
like yeah it was just adrenaline through
the roof I just thought obviously
thought about this whole time and I just
thought obviously what what could have
went on the other side as well um and
then just a long time coming your case
is similar to a guy in called Jordan
trenro he was very young a complete
fantasist invented stories similar about
him um and it ruined his life certainly
for a long time um and it Sparks again
this whole debate as we were saying
about the anonymity issue how do you
feel I mean do you feel after what
you've been through and indeed what
Jordan went through do do you think that
it's unfair that only the man who's
accused gets named do you think it would
be right to change the law so that if
you bring an allegation of rap both
sides get named or both sides are
Anonymous which do you think would be
fair I think both sides should
definitely be an anonymous until a point
of conviction of course
because because if you had been if the
law did that the papers couldn't have
mentioned your name nobody would have
known it was you you would have been
acquitted and no one would have known
anything about it
and you would sit here you wouldn't be
sitting here you wouldn't need to be mhm
because no one would know it was you
yeah of course and I think I probably
wouldn't be suspended either um
obviously because the clubs just got to
protect themselves on the pr
side um but I think the anonymity thing
obviously it's there to protect was it
cowardly of Sunderland to not let you
carry on until you were or if you were
convicted I mean if you you're an
innocent man yeah I think the suspension
happens a lot obviously I know a lot of
people lot of this has happened doing
and most of the time they get suspended
but I think just to make sure that the
players got the best thing especially in
football because obiously you see men's
rights men's mental health getting
preached everywhere now but this must
have devastated your mental health yeah
well it's it's that and there's there's
no real support you know what I mean you
get someone saying do you want to speak
to this counselor or something and no I
don't really want to because I don't
want to tell someone I don't know about
my problems I want be I want to be
playing football what are your feelings
towards the the girl who made these
allegations against
you I wouldn't say it's hatred I think
it's I'm embarrassed for her um do you
think it all got out of control that
yeah once her father found out and
reacted the way he did and the police
got involved she felt she just couldn't
go back on it yeah well the can't like
the police push it so much um CPS push
it so much to try and get these
conviction rates they want want higher
cu the conviction rate Ates for rape are
very very small a lot of women say well
we just don't complain because what's
the point they feel the systems unfair
to them yeah well I don't think the the
thing to do is to push every single one
through because you have ones like this
and ones like other scenarios which are
just a waste of everyone's time and
money how's it affected you with other
girls now I mean have you've been able
to have a relationship since no well
obviously because this has been going on
two years as well um obviously it was
known for a
year um but then even when it wasn't
known I wasn't publicly have you had any
sexual relationship at tool since no and
how
long about a year a year now since it's
been going on um since obviously I've
been named I'm not since you were
charged and named yeah um so a young man
and you you you just don't want to take
the the
chance that's that's terrible it's it's
crazy because even my friends obviously
my close friends now now when I tell
them how ridiculous and how how scary it
can actually be because it can be one
word against the other and then you go
on to court yeah um it can literally be
that easy so I tell them all to be
careful and they're like you know what
this has changed the way I look at like
you know as you would as a young lad
sometimes then they go out and you you
get a girl um it scared a lot of people
that I'm close to I'm sure Jack uh it's
good to meet you and thank you for being
so honest with the interview I think
it's awful what happened to you I think
it is something that you need to try and
put it behind you now if you can it's
very difficult I know that you'll be
reminded of it every match you play by
I'm sure opposition fans but in a way I
think what you said about having it fuel
you may make you an even better player
definitely you never know what doesn't
break you makes you stronger as the
saying right and I want to wish you all
the very best thank you very much unless
you play Arsenal and in that eventuality
I want you to lose no otherwise I hope
you win cheers good luck to you thank
you very
much